is the new iPhone 14 worth a hundred
dollars more than the iPhone 13 well
there are a ton of differences that
reviewers did not talk about so today
I'm gonna make the most detailed
comparison covering everything from the
new internal changes the displays
speakers the performance differences
including the new thermal system of
course the camera differences and much
more and I think you're gonna be very
surprised now the first thing that Apple
doesn't tell you is that the iPhone 14
can accept more than the 20 watts from
the charger that they sell you
separately because of course it's not
included in the box so pick up anchors
which is smaller it's a 30 watt so it'll
actually charge your iPhone faster we'll
leave a link in the description and well
guys while I was saying that look at
this red color that's a lot brighter
than in their photos I think that's my
favorite product I think you're right
our iPhone 13 is in Starlight now
externally it doesn't seem like there's
that many differences but let me points
them out to you first off on the right
hand side the 5G antenna is quite a bit
larger now nobody is mentioning this but
that's because the four teens have a new
5G chip just like the 14 pros and when
we tested that out outside the 14s were
almost twice as fast as far as
downloading outside and over 50 percent
faster in terms of uploading and it's
not only a difference in terms of 5G
when I switched over to LTE inside of
this office the download speed was over
four times faster and the upload speed
was almost four times faster that is a
massive difference now that was on the
14 pro Max but the 14 has the same chip
and antenna as this phone so if you
either upgrade or you choose to get the
iPhone 14 you will have better reception
and much faster speeds now with that
upgrade Apple also ditched the Sim slot
which is a downside for a lot of people
if your carrier doesn't and support it
or if you like to swap Sims but on the
plus side this thing can now have up to
eight or more e-sims with two enabled at
the same time where on the iPhone 13 you
can have two e-sims plus the physical
but overall I think that's still a
disappointment none of the buttons have
changed on this model so you might think
that you can reuse the same case but
nope because the camera bump has gotten
larger and with that it also is a little
bit thicker as well so you will have
more rocking on the table that is
because the camera's been updated as
larger rings and we also have a new
brighter flash that's more uniform which
we'll test in a little bit now
regardless of whether you upgrade to the
iPhone 14 or not one of the must-have
apps you should download is PDF elements
from our sponsor wondershare which is an
easy to use and affordable all-in-one
app that lets you edit convert annotate
organize sign and fill PDF forms and
documents across desktop mobile and the
web it's also got awesome features like
merging PDF files together scanning
documents and turning them into PDF
documents with digital signatures and
password protection support so check out
PDF element by using the link in the
description now people have been saying
that the 14 is basically just a copy
paste of the 13 but they're not talking
about a massive difference and that is
the internal changes with a 13 and
previous phones you would open them up
from the front and access all those
components but with the 14 you actually
open it up from the back glass and that
makes it much easier to replace it now
all the components are also completely
shifted around and there is now a metal
plate that we see from x-rays that can
also help with thermals so Apple had to
go through a ton of trouble changing
this up for people say it's the same
phone now what is the benefit to all of
us well on the iPhone 13 it costs you
449 dollars to replace a back glass if
you don't have AppleCare now it is only
169 dollars a much more palatable repair
so if you're not somebody that buys app
care that difference alone can make up
for the extra price of the 14. now a
couple awesome features are the new
crash detection and emergency SOS via
satellite features now these things are
awesome for safety crash protection is
great but you can also get that in the
new watches but the satellite
connectivity will allow you to connect
no matter where you are at so if you're
stuck you can send a message you can get
some help and that is something that is
great if you're going to be keeping this
phone for a long time the extra layer of
security the 14 also has a slightly
better battery life one extra hour of
video streaming and that's because it
does have a slightly larger battery now
the rated charging speeds haven't
changed but we know from our own testing
if you're using wireless charging while
you have the phone on for example if
you're using GPS in your car the
wireless charging slows down quite a bit
and because the new 14 has a new thermal
system it will charge faster now another
Hardware change is that the iPhone 14s
have Bluetooth 5.5 3 compared to 5.0 and
that will work great with the new Apple
watch series 8 or the new airpods Pro
because that Bluetooth uses less power
it has better range and also better call
Quality and audio quality so even if you
don't have one of those new devices now
chances are in the next one two three
years you will so that's definitely a
benefit the 14 also has dual ambient
light sensors which will help with auto
brightness on the front so if it didn't
work well for you in the past it's going
to get better and then on the back it
will help for camera exposure as well
the next thing that I want to test is
the speakers Apple didn't mention any
differences but the 14 pro Max is way
louder and sounds a lot better than the
13 Pro Max so I'm really curious about
these regular iPhones so let's go ahead
and take a listen
bring me back
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
you guys let me know your thoughts but
personally I think that if there is a
difference it might be extremely minor
so unfortunately the iPhone 14 does not
get the same nice speaker upgrade as the
14 Pros did now as far as it displays
some people have said that there are
some changes some pixels maybe the
bezels but it's not that noticeable but
in fact there are no differences
whatsoever the display is identical as
far as the maximum brightnesses the
colors the contrast HDR everything is
the same now I am a bit disappointed
that we don't have the promotion from
the Pro Line even if they did a worse
version of that that'd be nice because
all the Android competitors have that
and it would make people a lot more
happy to get the new 14. now one thing
that has changed that a lot of people
are downplaying is the new a15 processor
and what comes attached to that now yes
it is the five Graphics core model
compared to a 4G Graphics cores and
we'll test that out in a sec but what is
more important to me is the fact that
the 14 comes with six gigabytes of RAM
compared to four gigabytes and I don't
know why people don't talk about this in
my daily usage I compared these last
year the pro and the regular 13 and the
pro that had six gigs it kept apps open
way longer whereas the 13 model with
four gigs I would constantly be finding
myself with a YouTube app that closed I
have to go find that video again other
programs so it is so nice to have the
extra RAM and it definitely is a lot
more future proof now as far as the
actual CPU performance itself let's go
ahead and run geekbench and see what we
get so here are the first results and
it's a bit disappointing we have a very
slightly higher single core score pretty
much doesn't matter but in the
multi-core score it is actually lower by
about 250 points and yes this has been
updated to latest version of iOS that
actually makes it form better so that is
interesting now of course the main
change is in the graphics with that
extra Graphics core so let's go ahead
and run that and here are the results
this is a lot better we're seeing a
difference of 18 and a half percent in
terms of graphics performance and that
is a great thing but that brings me to
Thermal performance will this chip slow
down will the screen uh be dimmed
automatically because it gets too hot so
that's why I'm using antutu here I maxed
out the brightnesses on the display just
like if you're using it outside and
we're gonna see if we get any difference
in dimming I really hope the 14 is a lot
better so far both of them are exactly
the same I do see the iPhone 14 is
smoother because of its more performance
it also means that it's putting out a
bit more power and heat than the iPhone
13 but it's handling it oh look at that
the iPhone 14 dimmed not by that much
but you guys can see the clouds are a
lot brighter here on the 13 than it is
on the 14 so the screen is still dimming
because it's getting hotter right there
the 13 dimmed as well so it kept up a
little bit longer but now they are
pretty much matched up now I pulled out
my thermal camera and you guys could see
the iPhone 13 on the left it's at 39
degrees Celsius and has a smaller Hot
Spot compared to 40 on the 14 and that
heat is spreading out much more so now
that is actually a good thing because
Apple's thermal solution is taking that
heat away from the chip and putting it
into the body but that also means that
even though they haven't proved the
internals and The Thermals that extra
thermal performance is eaten up by the
increased graphics performance from that
fifth core and now let's talk about the
cameras because we do have a lot of
differences on stage Apple made it seem
like it was a huge upgrade and in some
cases they underplayed some things but
in other cases I think they exaggerated
starting out with our selfie camera we
now have an upgraded model that's the
same as on the 14 Pros but the biggest
change being the autofocus with the
front-facing camera so I took this shot
right here way too close up on purpose
it kind of looks weird but we could
definitely see that we have more detail
in the 14s photo the highlights pop a
little bit more we also have a little
bit more contrast and then I took one
from a further distance to see if the
autofocus matters and honestly to me I
mean I'm not seeing that much of a
difference now the real change comes
when you're shooting in low light they
set as up to two times better low light
performance and you can see here that we
have way less noise on the 14s photo now
this shot right here was done without
the night mode so when I enable that the
difference kind of goes away this is
slightly sharper it's slightly warmer in
fact it always does that with the 14s
but it's not that huge Improvement that
they talked about on stage now the
weakest camera on the iPhone 13 was its
Ultra wide and with the 14 they actually
didn't change any of the hardware but
they talked about their new photonic
engine and being able to use better
processing and using deep Fusion earlier
on for sharper images and when I zoom in
here honestly guys I'm not seeing much
of a difference actually slightly more
noise on the iPhone 14s photo but as far
as everything else I'm just seeing a
slightly more contrast now when you're
shooting in lower light with that Ultra
wide that is when we start to see a
difference with the 13 we have a lot
more noise here and less detail but the
new processing on the 14 reduces that
noise gives a little more contrast less
noise overall so that is a nice
Improvement now the lens that they
really focused on was the main camera it
is actually the same one from the iPhone
13 Pro It's a larger sensor has image
stabilization and in regular shots it's
hard to tell a difference in terms of
detail but we do see a difference in
terms of contrast so it's a little bit
warmer and more contrasty you can also
see those color differences with
portrait shots but as far as detail it
is not really that much better so as far
as quality it's not really that big of a
difference but what we do get is a
difference in low light that larger
sensor gives us a bit more detail less
noise we have a warmer image but what
you don't see with most images online is
the usability in that shot the 14 only
took one second for night mode compared
to 2 seconds and in reality it feels a
lot longer so you are going to get
sharper shots if you hold your phone for
just a little bit of time and it's just
a lot more convenient now the regular
iPhone 14s don't have a telephoto camera
so when I did the five times Zoom which
is the maximum and took these shots I
was hoping for some improvement in
detail but when we go ahead and zoom in
even more so if you're gonna crop
digitally we do see that we have a
little bit less noise because of the new
processing but if you look at that sign
where it says value Mission Center it's
readable on the old one but not on the
new one because it's just over processed
the iPhone 13 could do cinematic video
but it's only in 1080P and without HDR
so the new iPhone 14 enables 4K HDR it
definitely gives you extra detail and
extra dynamic range that the scene calls
for it so if you're somebody that uses
cinematic mode that is definitely a nice
Improvement for long-term quality of the
video now that also comes into play with
the front facing cinematic mode on the
iPhone 14 we see that we have better
dynamic range and we have 4K selected
but that's not the only difference you
can actually switch over to 24 frames
per second so if you're shooting with
the rear camera and you're trying to go
for that cinematic look that is the
frame rate that you want to go for and
only the 14 offers that now the 14s 1X
sensor is larger so in the shot you
could see that we get a little bit more
background blur because of that so that
is a positive thing but one thing that I
did not expect is that if you're taking
a close-up shot the larger sensor still
allows you to get just as close if not
slightly closer whereas last year the
pros they couldn't get as close because
that larger sensor that means that Apple
changed something up with these lenses
they've optimized it and it's actually
even better than it was before it is not
a downside and the last thing is the new
action mode that is exclusive to the 14
and 14 pros this is a software feature
that Apple could add to the 13 but they
didn't and as you guys see this footage
it's definitely a lot more smooth on the
iPhone 14 than the regular stabilization
now on stage when they announced this
action mode we saw a massive massive
difference and that is because Apple
turned off the stabilization on the 13
and had the action mode which is really
good on the 14. I was running outside in
the shot and as you guys could see the
difference isn't as big as it was on
stage but it still is a nice improvement
with just a little bit hit of quality
because it can't record in 4k so overall
I would say that this is a nice
Improvement in camera quality may be not
amazing in certain cases but just the
usability the lower light and the faster
shutter for night mode is really nice to
have along with those video upgrades so
if you want a better camera and you're
trying to decide I would definitely push
it towards the 14 and now getting into
should you buy the 14 over the 13 at 100
less well when I looked at videos online
and the specs it didn't really seem like
it is a nice upgrade at all kind of like
Apple's ripping us off but once we
factor in the new crash detection the
satellite we factor in the better
battery life the better performance that
six gigs of RAM of course that really
nice Improvement in cellular speed and
uh reception when you look at it it is
definitely worth spending the extra
hundred dollars on the 14. if I was
going to recommend one of these to
friends and family even those that are
not into Tech I would absolutely say buy
the 14. now if you already have a 13
should you upgrade to 14 no I don't
think so you should save up a bit more
money for the 14 pro or just wait
another year for the iPhone 15 or maybe
even the 16 but there you guys go those
are all of the differences what oh so
many of the reviewers did not mention so
if you guys got some value and you guys
enjoy this video go ahead and click that
Circle above to subscribe check out one
of those great videos right over there
the spin Max and I'll see you in the
next video
[Music]